>>There will be growth in the global economy
in 2009. Even in the United States, I think
the second half you're going to start to see
little signs of recovery. The global economy
was smashed as was the U.S. economy by the
financial crisis. If the new administation
gets a few things right or stops making mistakes
by the law of averages, we are due for some
good decisions from Washington. This thing
will start,basic strengths will start to come
through. For example, one of the things the
Obama Administration get rid of is this,this
strange accounting rule called mark to market.
Which has devastated bank balance sheets.
A bank makes a loan now it knows it's probably
going to have to take a hit to it's capital
because even if the principle is being paid,
interest is being paid. Banks if they have
to sell the loan tomorrow, which they won't,
but if regulators come in and say "If you
had to sell the loan tomorrow what price would
you get?" They'd have to take a write-down
on it. Which is crazy. If we had that rule
in the early 90's when we had a banking crisis
we would have destroyed most commercial banks
in the United States. So get rid of mark-to-market
and that way banks can rebuild their balance
sheets. And the other thing that I think the
administration will do- it's right up their
alleys-government activism. Is that the housing
market revive by having either the Federal
Reserve or Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac go to
banks and say we'll buy your mortgages. Any
mortgages you write with a fixed interest
rate of 4.5-5% long-term. Rates are low now
for mortgages but banks aren't making the
loans. But if they know that they can sell
the mortgages to Fannie and Freddie or to
the Federal Reserve, they'll start writing
the loans again and get the housing market
moving. So a couple of basic things like that
would go a long ways and get things moving.